The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to pretty much
finish up today talking
about modulation.
Part of the reason we don't
spend much time on this is, I
think most of you have seen
some kind of undergraduate
class in communication
or signal
processing or something.
Where you do a lot of this
because a lot of this is just
nice exercises and -- well, nice
or not nice, depending on
the way you about it -- in
multiplying waveforms by
cosines and by sines and by
complex exponentials.
And you keep doing this, and
doing this, and doing this and
you get these long
expressions.
And and it all means
something.
So, most of you have seen
a good deal of this.
You probably haven't seen the
Nyquist criterion before.
I'm sure you haven't seen the
Nyquist criterion done
carefully, because I've never
seen it done carefully before.
I don't think it is done
carefully anywhere else.
And I'm sure you don't
care about this.
But, at some point, if you deal
with this stuff, you will
care about it.
Because at some point
you will need it.
But anyway, we were looking at
pulse amplitude modulation,
you remember.
We were looking at the
modulated waveform.
And this is all done down at
baseband, now, remember.
And the interesting problems
down at baseband are, first,
how do you choose
a signal set.
Namely, how do you choose those
quantities u sub k, out
of some set of possible
values.
So they have an appropriate
distance between them.
And, next, how do you choose
this waveform p of t, which is
called the pulse, that
you're using.
And then, after you've chosen
those two things, there's
nothing more to be done.
You simply form the modulated
waveform as u of t equals the
sum of the signals which are
coming in regularly at
intervals of t.
You multiply each one of them
by this waveform, p of t.
Or, alternatively, you think of
the waveform as being a sum
of impulses.
Each impulse weighted
by u sub k.
And you think of passing this
string of impulses through a
filter with impulse
response p of t.
Which is usually the way that
it's implemented, except of
course you're not using
ideal impulses.
You're using sharp pulses which
have a flat spectrum
over the bandwidth of
the filter p of t.
But anyway, somehow or other
you implement this.
And that is this fundamental
step we've been talking about
for quite a while now,
of how do you turn
sequences into waveforms.
How do you turn waveforms into
sequences, it's a fundamental
piece of source coding.
It's a fundamental piece
of channel coding.
Here we're doing the channel
coding part of it.
Then we did something
kind of flaky.
We said that when we received
this waveform, what we were
going to do is to first pass it
through another filter, and
then sample it.
If you've done the homework yet,
you will probably have
looked at what happens when you
take an arbitrary linear
operation on this received
signal to try to retrieve what
these signals u sub k are.
And you will have found that
this filtering and sampling is
in fact not a general linear
operation, but it's the only
general linear operation that
you're interested in as far as
retrieving these signals
from that waveform.
So, in fact, this is, in fact,
more general than it looks.
There a confusing thing here.
If you receive u of t at the
receiver, and your question
is, how do we get this sequence
of samples u sub k
out of it, and suppose that this
pulse p of t or the --
I mean, suppose for example
that the pulse is a narrow
bandwidth pulse, and there's
just no way you can perform
linear operations and get these
signals out from it.
Is it possible to do nonlinear
operations and get the signals
out from it?
And you ought to think about
this question a little bit
because it's kind of
an interesting one.
If I don't tell you what the
signals u sub k are, if I ask
you to build something which
extracts these samples u sub
k, without any idea of what
signal set they're taken from,
then there's nothing
you can do better
than a linear operation.
And, in fact, if this pulse p
of t has a bandwidth that's
too narrow, you're just stuck.
If I tell you that these u sub
k are drawn from a particular
signal set -- for example,
suppose they're binary -- then
you have an enormous extra
amount of information.
And you can, in fact, given this
waveform, even though p
of t is a very, very narrow
band, you can still in
principle get these binary
signals out.
So what's the game we're
playing here?
I mean, we're doing kind
of a phony thing.
We're restricting ourselves
to only linear operations.
We are restricting ourselves
to retrieving these signals
without knowing anything about
what the signal set is.
Which is not really the problem
that we're interested
in looking at.
So what are we really doing?
What we're really doing is
trying to look at this
question of modulation
before we look at
the question of noise.
And after we start looking at
noise, the thing that we're
going to find is that this
received waveform is a
received waveform plus a lot
of noise on top of it.
And if there's a lot of noise on
top of it, these non-linear
operations you can think
of are not going
to work very well.
And I guess the problem is, you
just have to take that on
faith right now.
And after we look at random
processes, and after we look
at how to deal with the noise
waveforms, you will in fact
see that these operations we're
talking about here are
exactly the things
we want to do.
Now, I don't know whether
this is the right
way to do it or not.
Dealing with all this phony
stuff that you see in
elementary courses before
dealing with the real stuff.
I think it probably is, because
for most of you this
is sort of familiar and
we'll come back later
and make it all right.
But who knows?
Anyway.
what we want to do then is to
find some composite filter, g,
which is what happens when you
take the filter p, or the
pulse p, pass it through a
filter q of t, what you get is
the convolution of p and q.
And, therefore, what comes out
after this filtering is done
is a received waveform which is
just a sum over k of u sub
k times g of t minus k t.
In other words, these two
filters are not doing anything
extra for you.
All they are is a way of putting
part of the filter at
the transmitter, part of the
filter at the receiver.
When you look at noise you'll
find out that there is some
real difference between what's
done at the transmitter and
what's done at the receiver,
because the noise comes in
between the transmitter
and the receiver.
But for now, it doesn't make
any difference so the only
thing we're interested in is
the properties of this
composite waveform, g of t.
And what we find is that if we
receive r of t, which is this
waveform sum of u k g of t minus
k t, and if we want to
retrieve the coefficient u sub
k, it becomes duck soup to do
so if in fact this waveform is
like a sampling waveform.
In other words, if g of t is
equal to 1 at t equals 0, and
it's equal to 0 at each other
sample point, then all we have
to do is take this waveform,
simply sample it each capital
T seconds, and we get these
coefficients out
automatically.
Now, I should warn you at this
point that in the notes the
scaling business is not
done quite right.
Sometimes we talk about g of t
as a filter whose shifts are
orthonormal to each other.
And sometimes as a filter whose
shifts are orthogonal to
each other.
I advise you not to worry about
that, because you have
to make changes about five
times in the notes
to make it all right.
And I will put up a new version
of the notes on the
web which in fact
does this right.
It's not important.
It's just this old question of,
do you use a sinc function
when you're dealing with
strictly band-limited
functions, or do you multiply
the sinc function by 1 over
the square root of t to
make it orthonormal.
Or do you multiply it by
1 over t to make it --
I mean, you can scale it in a
number of different ways.
And, fundamentally, it doesn't
make any difference.
It's just that if you want to
get the right answer you have
to scale it the right way.
And it's not quite right
in the notes.
So I'll change it around and
send the thing out to you.
Then it says that T-spaced
samples of r then reproduce u
sub k without intersymbol
interference.
The Nyquist criterion is
different from this business
of the pulse being
ideal Nyquist.
Ideal Nyquist is talking
about the time domain.
It simply says the trivial thing
you, want a pulse which
has 0's at every sample point
except for the sample point
you're interested in.
The Nyquist criterion translates
that ideal Nyquist
property, in time, to a
property in frequency.
And it says that the frequency,
that the Fourier
transform of g of t has
to satisfy this
relationship here.
And there's this added condition
on g of f that it
has to go to 0 fast enough
as f goes to infinity.
But we won't worry
about that today.
So the condition is this: the
picture that I showed you last
time is this.
We defined the nominal band, the
Nyquist band, as the base
bandwidth w equals 1 over 2t.
That's the bandwidth that a sinc
pulse would have if you
were using a sinc pulse.
The actual baseband limit,
b, should be close to w.
And most of the work that people
do trying to build
filters and things like this,
since what we're trying to do
is find a waveform that we're
trying to transmit.
And we're stuck with the FCC
and all these other things
that say, you better keep
this band-limited.
What we're going to do is to
make the actual band of the
waveform close to the
nominal bandwidth.
So we're going to assume that
it's less than twice the
nominal bandwidth.
In other words, you can have a
little bit of slop, but you
can't have too much.
When you try to design a filter
that way, and you
satisfy the Nyquist criterion,
which is talking about all of
these bands all the way out to
infinity, and the fact they
have to add up in a certain
way, if you only have this
band here and part of
the next band --
if this function has to go to
0 before you get out to 2w,
then the only thing you have
to worry about is what does
this waveform look like here.
You take this and
you pick it up.
And you put it over here,
and you add it up.
You take this, you put it over
here and you add it up.
And if the pulse, p of t is
real, then what you have over
here is the complex conjugate
of what you have here.
And if you make this real in
frequency also -- in other
words, you have symmetry
in time and symmetry in
frequency, then this band edge
symmetry requirement is that
when you add this to this, you
get something which is an
ideal rectangular pulse.
Now, if you think of taking this
waveform here -- now you
only have to worry about the
positive frequency part of it.
And you take that point right
there, which is halfway
between 0 and t.
In other words, this
is at t over 2.
And it's also at frequency w.
And you rotate this thing around
by 180 degrees, then
this comes up there.
And it fills in this little
slot up here.
That's what the band edge
symmetry means.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, yes.
We could, if we wanted
to, put various
notches in this filter.
But we've defined the bandwidth,
b, as the largest
frequency, f, such that g
hat of f is 0 beyond b.
In other words, everywhere
beyond b, g hat of
f is equal to 0.
Now, if g hat f cuts down to 0,
say, back here, there's no
way you can meet the
Nyquist criterion.
Because there's no way you can
build this thing up with all
these out-of-band components
so that you get something
which is flat all the
way out to w.
So you simply can't have a
filter which is band-limited
to a frequency less than w.
What you need is to use these
out-of-band frequencies as a
way to help you construct this
ideal rectangular pulse.
Through aliasing.
In other words, the point
here is when we're doing
transmission of data, we
know what the data is.
We know what the filter
is, and we can use
aliasing to our advantage.
When we were talking about data
compression, aliasing
just hurt us.
Because we were trying to
represent this waveform that
we didn't have any
control over.
And the out-of-band parts added
into the baseband parts
and they clobbered us.
Because we couldn't get the
whole thing back again.
Here, we're doing it
the other way.
In, other words we're starting
out with a sequence.
We're going to a waveform, and
then we're trying to get the
sequence back from
the waveform.
So it's really the opposite
kind of problem.
And here, the whole game,
namely, the thing that Nyquist
spotted, back in 1928, was you
could use these out-of-band
frequencies to, in fact, help
you to get rid of this
intersymbol interference.
Because all you need to do is
make these things add up to
this so that you have something
rectangular.
And then when you do
the samples, you
have to write samples.
Now, the problem that a filter
designer comes to when saying
this is to say, OK, how do I
design a frequency response
which has the property that
it's going to go to 0
quickly beyond w.
Because the FCC, when we
translate this up to passband,
is going to tell us we can't
have much energy outside of
minus w to plus w.
And if we can't design a good
filter, it means we have to
make w smaller.
So we can keep ourselves within
this given bandwidth.
And we don't want to do that
because that keeps us from
transmitting much data.
And then we can't sell our
product, so suddenly we have
to design something which uses
all of this bandwidth that we
have available.
So what we want to do, then, is
to design something where b
is just a little bit more than
w, but where also we get from
t down to 0 very quickly.
We could just use the square
pulse to start with.
And what's the trouble
with that?
This rectangular pulse, its
inverse Fourier transform is
the sinc pulse.
The sinc pulse, because a
discontinuity in the Fourier
transform, it can't go to 0 any
faster than is 1 over t.
And suddenly it goes to
0 as 1 over t goes to
0 very, very slowly.
In other words, you have
enormous problems over time.
And you have enormous delay.
And since you have so many
pulses adding up together,
everything has to be done
extraordinarily carefully.
So what you want is a pulse
which remains equal to t over
a y bandwidth here.
Which gets down to 0
very, very fast.
So the problem is, how do you
design something which gets
from here down to
here very, very
quickly and very smoothly.
You want it to go smoothly
because if you have any
discontinuities in g of f,
you're back to the problem
where g of t goes to
0 as 1 over t.
If you have a slope
discontinuity, g of t is going
to go to 0 as 1 over
t squared.
If you have a second derivative
discontinuity, it's
going to go to 0 as
1 over t cubed.
Now, 1 over t cubed is not bad,
and filter designers sort
of live with that.
So they design these filters
which are raised cosine
filters, which over the band
here -- someday I'll get a pen
that works -- are flat.
Over this band here, from here
to here, this is a squared
cosine, analytically.
And a squared cosine is just the
same as a cosine which you
take and displace up so it's
centered right there.
Well, excuse me, it's
the same as a sine
which is centered there.
Which is what you get when
you square a cosine
pulse as 1/2 plus.
Anyway, it looks like this.
So our problem is, how do you
design a filter which gets
from here to there quickly but
where the inverse transform
also goes to 0 relatively
quickly?
Now, if you want to do this
and you also face the fact
that in a Nyquist criterion, any
part of g hat of f which
is imaginary, the Nyquist
criterion says that what do
you have to do in-band and what
you have to do out of
band have to add
up there also.
That doesn't help you at all
in getting from this real
number t here down to 0.
So anything you do as a complex
part of g hat of f is
just wasted.
I mean, your problem is getting
from t to 0 with a
smooth waveform.
You would like to make g
hat of f strictly real.
You would like to make
it symmetric.
Why would you like to
make it symmetric?
Because this thing down here
and this thing up here are
really part of the
same problem.
If you find a good way to make
a function go to 0 quickly up
here, you might as well use
the same thing over here.
So you might as well wind up
with a function which is
symmetric and real.
That leads us into the next
thing we want to look at.
That's a slightly
flaky argument.
We're going to find a better
argument as we go.
What we've said is, the real
part of g hat of f has to
satisfy this band edged
symmetry condition.
Choosing the imaginary part
unequal to 0 simply increases
the energy outside of
the Nyquist band.
You don't get any effect on
reducing delay out of that.
Thus, we're going to restrict
g of f to be real.
And we're going to also restrict
it to be symmetric.
Although that's less
important.
Now, when we start to look at
noise, we're going to find out
something else.
We're going to find out that we
want to make the magnitude
of p of f equal to the
magnitude of g of f.
Now, magnitude doesn't
make any difference.
So we want the frequency
characteristic of p of f to be
the same as the frequency
characteristic of q of f.
In other words, there's no
point descending a p of f
which is a perfect sinc function
and then using a very
sloppy q of f.
Because that's kind of silly.
There's no point to using it
very sloppy p of f and then
using a very sharp q of f,
because somehow when you start
looking at noise, you're going
to lose everything.
Because the noise gets added
to this pulse that you're
transmitting.
So, what we're going to find
when we look at this later, is
we really want to choose
the magnitudes
of these to be equal.
Since g hat of f is equal to
this product, and since we've
already decided we want to
make this real, what this
means is that q hat of f is
going to be equal to p complex
conjugate of f.
What that means is the filter q
of t should be equal to the
complex conjugate
of p of minus t.
You take a p of t, and you
turn it around like this.
If p of t is real, this is
called a matched filter.
And it's a filter which sort of
collects everything which
is in p of t, and all brings it
up to 1p, which is what we
would like to do here.
So, anyway, when we do this it
means that g of t is going to
be this convolution of p of t.
And q of t, which we can now
write as the integral of p of
tau, times p complex conjugate
of t minus tau, p tau.
And what we're interested in is,
is this going to be ideal
Nyquist or not.
And what does that mean if
it is ideal Nyquist?
If g of t is ideal Nyquist, it
means that the samples of g of
t, times k times this signaling
interval, t, have to
have the property that these
samples are equal to 1 for k
equals 0, and 0 for
k unequal to 0.
What does that mean?
If you look at this, that
kind of looks like these
orthogonality conditions that
we've been dealing with,
doesn't it?
So that what it says is that
this set of functions, p
of t minus k t.
In other words, the pulse p of
t and all of it shifts by t,
2t, 3t, and everything else.
This set of pulses all have to
be orthogonal to each other.
And the thing which is a little
screwed up in the notes
is whether these are
orthogonal or
orthonormal, or what.
And you need to make
a few changes to
make all of that right.
These functions are all
real L2 functions.
But we're going to allow the
possibility of complex
functions for later.
In other words, if we're
transmitting a baseband
waveform on a channel,
how do you transmit
an imaginary waveform?
Well, I've never seen anything
in electromagnetics, or in
optics, or anything else,
that lets me transmit
an imaginary waveform.
These are not physical.
We will often think of baseband
waveforms that are imaginary.
Real and imaginary complex.
And when we translate them up
to baseband, we'll find
something real.
But the actual waveforms
that get
transmitted are always real.
There's no way you
can avoid that.
That's real life.
Real life is real.
That's why they call
it real, I guess.
it real life.
I don't know.
I mean it's more real than
something imaginary, isn't it?
So, anyway, what gets
transmitted is real.
But we'll allow p of t to be
complex just for when we start
dealing with something called
QAM, which is our next topic.
So in vector terms, the integral
of u of tau times q
of k t minus tau is the
projection of u
of t onto this waveform.
And partly for that reason, q
of t it's called the matched
filter to p of t.
In other words, you use this
waveform here as a way of
selecting out the parts of this
waveform u of tau, u of
t, that we're interested in.
So that any way you look at it,
we're going to use a pulse
waveform, p of t, which has this
property that its shifts
are all orthogonal
to each other.
When we start studying noise,
you will be very thankful that
we did this.
Because when you use pulses that
are orthogonal to each
other, you can break
up the noise into
an orthogonal expansion.
And what goes on at one place
is completely independent of
what goes on at every
other place.
And we'll find out about
this as we go.
But, anyway, we have the nice
property now, that anytime we
find a function g of t, that
satisfies the Nyquist
criterion And any time we choose
p of t and g of t so
that their Fourier transforms
have the same magnitude, then
presto, we have freely
gotten a set
of orthonormal functions.
Which just comes out
in the wash.
Before we worked very hard to
get these truncated sinusoid
expansions and sinc weighted
sinusoid expansions, and all
of this stuff to generate
different
orthonormal sets of waveforms.
Suddenly, we just have an
orthonormal set of waveforms
and a very large set of
orthonormal waveforms popping
up and staring us in
the face here.
And in fact these are the
waveforms we're going to use
for communication, so
they're nice things.
Nobody uses sinc functions
for communication.
Nobody uses rectangular
functions.
You can't use either one of
them because rectangular
functions have lousy frequency
characteristics.
Sinc functions have lousy
time characteristics.
These functions p of t are
sort of nice compromises.
And they're orthonormal,
again.
Let's go on to the rest
of modulation.
We've been talking about
baseband modulation.
And when we're thinking about
PAM, pulse amplitude
modulation, we are thinking in
terms of this sequence of
symbols coming in.
The symbols being turned
into signals.
The signals been turned
into waveforms.
And what comes out here, then,
is some baseband waveform.
That's what the Nyquist
criterion is designed for.
How do you make a baseband
waveform which is very sharply
cut off in frequency?
Usually what we want to transmit
is something at
passband, so we somehow want
to take this baseband
waveform, convert it
up to passband.
We're then going to transmit
it on a channel.
I mean, why do we have to turn
it into passband anyway?
Well, if you did everything at
baseband, you wouldn't have
more than one channel
available.
I mean, wireless, you
know you have all
these different channels.
The way it's done today, you
use something called CDMA,
where you're not breaking
into narrow channels.
But you should understand how
to break it into narrow
channels before understanding
how to look at it as
co-division multiple access.
If you're using optics, you
want to send things in
different frequency bands.
Whether it's optics or
electromagnetics simply
determines the frequency band
you're looking at anyway.
You can't propagate things
in every frequency band.
Things don't propagate very
well at baseband.
So for all of these reasons,
we want to convert these
baseband waveforms
to passband.
Why don't we generate them
originally at passband?
Because things are changing
too fast there.
I mean, you want to do digital
signal processing to massage
these signals, to do
all the filtering.
To do most of the other
things you want to do.
And you can do those very
easily at baseband.
And it's hard to do
them at passband.
So the generic way things
are done is to first
take a signal sequence.
Convert it into a baseband
waveform.
Take the baseband waveform,
convert it up to passband.
And the passband is appropriate
to whatever the
channel is.
You send it.
You take it down from passband
back to baseband, and then you
filter and sample and get
the waveform back again.
You don't have to do this.
We could generate the waveform
directly at passband.
There's a lot of research going
on now trying to do
this, which is trying to make
things a little bit simpler.
Well, it's not really trying
to make things simpler.
It's really trying to trying
to pull a fast one
on the FCC, I think.
But, anyway, this
is being done.
And it doesn't go through this
two-step process on the way.
So it saves a little
extra work.
So what we're going to do with
our PAM waveform, them, we're
going to take u of t, which
is the PAM waveform.
And I'm sure you've
all seen this.
I hope you've all seen it
somewhere or other.
Because everybody likes
to talk about this.
Because you don't have to know
anything to talk about this.
So you take u of t.
We multiply it by e to
the 2 pi i f c t.
In other words, you multiply
it by a sine wave.
A complex sine wave.
When you do this, this
thing is complex.
You can't transmit it.
So what do we do about that?
Well, this is real.
This is complex.
If we add the complex conjugate
of this, this plus
its complex conjugate
is real again.
So we transmit this times this
complex sinusoid, plus this
other complex sinusoid,
which is the complex
conjugate of this.
And you get 2 u of t times
the cosine of 2 pi f c t.
Which is just what you would
do if you were implementing
this anyway.
You take the waveform u of t,
you multiply it by cosine wave
at the carrier frequency.
And bingo, up it goes to
carrier frequency.
This is real.
This was real.
And everybody's happy.
And in frequency, what this
looks like, since all we're
doing here is just, by this
shift formula that we have for
Fourier transforms, the
multiplying a time waveform by
an exponential --
by a complex sinusoid, is simply
is the same as shifting
the frequency response.
So the Fourier transform
of this is u hat of
that minus f c.
The Fourier transform of u f
t times this is u hat of
f the plus f c.
And you start out with this
waveform, whatever
that shape is here.
This, I tried to draw to satisfy
the Nyquist criteria,
which it does it.
Satisfies that band edge
symmetry condition.
So this gets shifted up.
It also gets shifted down.
And the transmitted waveform
then exists in the band which
I'll call b sub u. b sub u is
the bandwidth of u of t.
Namely, it's this baseband
bandwidth that we've been
talking about.
But, unfortunately, when we do
this thing shifted up and this
thing shifted down, the overall
bandwidth here is now
twice as much as
it was before.
Now, every communication
engineer in the world, I
think, measures bandwidth
in the same way.
When you talk about bandwidth,
you're always talking about
positive bandwidth.
Because, back a long time ago,
communication engineers didn't
know about complex sinusoids.
So everything was done in terms
of cosines and sines.
Which was very good, because
back then communication
engineers didn't have
much else to do.
So they had to learn to write
everything twice.
And now, since we have so many
other things to worry about,
we want to use complex sinusoids
and only write
things once.
Well, in fact we have to write
it twice here, but we don't
write it twice very often.
But, anyway, when this thing,
which exists for minus b u up
to plus b u gets translated
up in frequency, we have
something which exists from f
c minus b u to f c plus b u.
And this negative band
is down here.
Now, we're going to assume
everywhere, usually without
talking about it, that when we
modulate this up in frequency,
that the bandwidth here, this
b u here, is less than the
carrier frequency.
In other words, when we
translate it up in frequency,
this and this do not intersect
with each other.
If this and this intersected
with each other, it would be
something very much
like aliasing.
You just couldn't to sort
out from this, plus
this, what this is.
Here, if I drew it on paper at
least, if you tell me what
this is, I can figure
out what that is.
Namely, demodulating it
independent of how we design
the demodulator is, in some
sense trivial, too.
You just take this and
you bring it back
down to passband again.
Well, anyway, since
communication engineers define
bandwidth in terms of positive
frequencies, the bandwidth of
this baseband waveform
is b sub u.
The bandwidth of this waveform
is 2 b sub u.
You can't get away from that.
You have doubled the bandwidth,
and you wind up
with this plus this.
And this looks kind
of strange.
So let's try to sort it out.
The baseband waveform
is limited to b.
If it's shifted up to passband,
the passband
waveform becomes
limited to 2 b.
Might as well put these
little u's in here.
Because putting in little u's
here is a way of getting
around the problem of talking
about baseband
waveforms for a while.
And then talking about
passband waveforms.
And one of them is always
twice the other one.
If you filter out this lower
band here, now, what's the
lower sideband here?
Who thinks the lower
sideband is this?
Who thinks the lower sideband
is this little thing here?
Well, you all should
think that because
that's what it is.
So when people talk about
sidebands, what they're
referring to, it's not, this
is one sideband and this is
another sideband.
What they're referring to is
this is one sideband and this
is one sideband.
This is stuff you all
know, I'm sure.
But haven't thought
about for a while.
If you filter out this lower
sideband, then this resulting
waveform, which now runs only
in this upper sideband here,
and since it has to be real it
has this accompanying lower
sideband down here going with
it, but you then have the
frequency band b sub u
like you had before.
So, in principle, you can design
a communication system
by translating things up in
frequency by the carrier, and
then chopping off that
lower sideband.
And then you haven't gained
anything in frequency.
And everything is essentially
the same as it was before.
Now, this used to be a very
popular thing to do with
analog communication.
Partly because communication
engineers felt the only thing
they had to study back then was,
how do you change things
in frequency and how do
you build filters.
So they're very good at this.
They love to do this.
And this was their
preferred way of
dealing with the problem.
They just got rid of that
sideband, sent this positive
sideband, and then somehow
they would get it
back down to here.
Single sideband is hardly
ever used for digital
communication.
It's not the usual way
of doing things.
Partly because these filters
become very tricky when you're
trying to send data
at a high speed.
All sorts of noise in here when
you try to do this and
you don't do it quite right.
Affects you enormously, and
people have just seen over the
years that those systems don't
work as well as the systems
which do something else that
we'll talk about later.
Namely, QAM, which is what
we want to talk about.
If you don't do this filtering,
you call this
system a double sideband pulse
amplitude modulation system.
Which is what happens when
you use pulse amplitude
modulation.
Namely, this baseband choosing a
baseband pulse, which is the
thing we're interested in.
Because that's where the Nyquist
criterion and all this
neat stuff comes in.
And then you translate
it up in frequency.
And you waste half the
available frequency.
If you don't care about
frequency management, this is
a fine thing to do.
Nothing wrong with it.
You just waste some frequency.
It's the cheapest way
to do things.
And there are lots of
cheap communication
systems which do this.
But if you're trying to send
data, if you're concerned
about the frequency efficiency
of the system, then you're not
going to do this.
So what we're going to do is do
something called quadrature
amplitude modulation.
QAM, which is what quadrature
amplitude modulation stands
for, solves the frequency
waste problem of double
sideband amplitude modulation
by using a complex baseband
waveform u of t.
Before, what we were talking
about is these signals which
were one-dimensional signals.
We would use these
one-dimensional signals to
modulate this waveform p of t.
And we wound up with
a real waveform.
Now what we're going to do is
use complex signals, which
then have two dimensions.
Use them to modulate
the same sort of
pulse, p of t, usually.
And wind up with a complex
baseband waveform.
And then we're going to take
that baseband waveform,
translate it up in frequency.
So when we do this,
what do we get?
We need a waveform to transmit
which is real.
So we're going to take u
of t, which is complex.
Translate, shift it
up in frequency
by the carrier frequency.
So we get u of t times e
to the 2 pi i f c t.
To make it real, we have to
add all this junk down at
negative frequencies, which we'd
just as soon not think
about if we didn't have to.
But they have to be there.
So our total waveform is x sub
t equal this sum of things.
When you look at this and you
take the real part of this,
the real part of this, the
imaginary part of this, and
the imaginary part of this, as
I'm sure most of you have seen
before, x of t becomes 2 times
the real part of u of t.
Times this complex
exponential.
Which is equal to 2 times the
real part of u of t times this
cosine wave minus 2 times the
imaginary part of u of t times
a sine wave.
Which says, you take this real
part of this baseband waveform
you've generated.
You multiply it by
cosine wave.
You take the imaginary part,
and you multiply
it by a sine wave.
For implementation, is one thing
going to be real and the
other thing imaginary?
No.
You can't make things that are
imaginary, so you just deal
with two real waveforms.
And you call one of them the
real part of u of t.
You call the other one the
imaginary part of u of t.
And the imaginary part of
u of t is in fact a
real waveform again.
So all this imaginary stuff is
just in our imagination.
And the actual waveforms
look like this.
You take one waveform
which is generated.
Multiply it by cosine.
Take another waveform.
Multiply it by sine.
What about these factors
of two here?
The factors of two are things
that drive everybody crazy.
Everyone I talk to, I ask them
how they manage to keep all
this straight.
And they all give me the same
answer: they say they can't
keep it straight.
It's just too hard to keep it
straight, and after they're
all done, they try to figure out
what the answer should be
by looking at energy
or something else.
Or by just fudging things, which
is what most people do.
And part of the trouble is,
you can do this two ways.
You can do it three
ways, in fact.
You can either I want to view
x of t as being some real
function times the cosine wave
and leave out that 2.
And some other function,
imaginary part of u t times
the sine, and leave
out the 2 there.
And many people do that.
And would that be better?
But when you put the 2 in with
the cosines and the sines, you
have to put a 1/2 in here
and a 1/2 in here.
Most people, when they think
about these things for a long
time, they find it's far more
convenient to be able to think
of this positive frequency part
of x of t as just u of t
translated up in frequency.
In other words, they like
this diagram here.
Which says you take this.
You translate it up.
And after you translate it up,
you create something else down
here, to make the whole
thing real.
But what we think of is this
going up to this all the time.
So that's one way of doing it.
The other way of doing it is
thinking in terms of sines and
cosines, removing that 2 here.
And who can imagine what the
third way of doing it is?
Just split the difference.
Which means you put a
square root of 2 in.
And, in fact, that makes
a whole lot of sense.
Because then when you take the
waveform u of t, translate it
up in frequency.
Make it real, you have the same
energy in the baseband
waveform as you have in
the passband waveform.
I'm not going to show that.
You can just figure it out
relatively easily.
I mean, you know that the power
in a cosine wave is 1/2,
the power in a sine
wave is 1/2.
So when you're multiplying
things by 1/2 in here -- well,
this has a power of 1/2.
This has a power of 1/2.
And when you start looking at
power here, you find out that
that has to be a square root
of 2 rather than 2.
So there are three
ways of doing it.
People do it any one of
three different ways.
It doesn't make any difference,
because any paper
you read will start out doing
it one way and then, as they
go through various equations,
they will start doing it a
different way.
And these factors of
2 multiply and
multiply and multiply.
And in big complicated papers,
sometimes I've found that
these add up to a factor of
8 or 16 or something else.
By the time people
are all done.
And we will explain later why,
in fact, you don't really care
about that very much.
But you can't just
totally ignore
those factors, so anyway.
This is the way we will do it.
We will try to be consistent
about this, and
usually we will be.
The way we want to think about
this conceptually is that
quadrature amplitude modulation
is going to take
this complex waveform u of t.
It's going to shift it up in
frequency to f sub c, and then
we're going to add the
complex conjugate.
Add it to form the
real x sub t.
In other words, we're
going to think of it
as a two-stage operation.
First you take waveform,
you translate it up.
Then you take the real part or
something, or add the negative
frequency part.
And we're going to think both of
this double operation of 1
going from u of t
to the positive
frequency part of things.
And then, of looking at
the real waveform that
corresponds to that.
What we're going to be doing
here in terms of all of this
is, we're going to start
out with binary data.
From the binary data, we're
going to go to symbols.
And we're going to go to symbols
by taking a number of
binary data --
a number of binary digits.
Framing then into b tuples.
Each b tuple will correspond
to a set
of 2 to the b symbols.
We're going to map these symbols
into complex signals.
We're going to map the complex
signals into a baseband
waveform u of t.
We're going to map the baseband
waveform u of t into
this positive frequency waveform
u of t times this
complex sinusoid.
And finally we're going to add
on the negative frequency part
to wind up with x of t.
What do you think we
do at the receiver?
As always, we do just
the opposite.
Namely, one of the reasons for
wanting to think about this
this way, is we want to use
this layering idea.
And the layering idea says,
you start out with the
received waveform x of t.
And later on we'll have to
add the noise to it.
You go from there to the
positive frequency part.
You go from the positive
frequency part.
You shift it down to u of t.
How we got from here to there,
I'll explain in a minute.
You go from here down
to baseband again.
You go from the baseband to
the complex signals, which
we're going to do simply by
filtering and sampling.
We go from the complex signals
to the symbols, which is in
fact a trivial operation.
It's just a look-up operation.
And then from there we
un-segment things into binary
digits again.
So that's the whole system.
And it has all these different
pieces to it.
I couldn't draw it as our
favorite kind of diagram,
because it has too many
blocks in it.
So that has to do.
What we're going to do now is
look at each of these pieces
one at a time.
And the first part is the
complex QAM signal set.
And, just for some notation
here, so we'll be on the same
page, but we use r to talk about
the bits per second at
which data is coming into
this whole system.
That's the figure you're
interested in, when
everything is done.
How many bits per second
can you transmit?
We're going to segment this
into b bits at a time.
So we're going to have a symbol
set with 2 to the b
elements in it.
We're going to map these m
symbols, which are binary b
tuples, into elements
from the signal set.
The signal rate, then, is r
sub s, which is r over b.
This is the number of signals
per second that we're sending.
In other words, t, this signal
interval that we've always
been using in everything
we've been doing, is
one over r sub s.
So t is the signal interval.
Every t seconds, you've
got to send something.
If you didn't send something
every t seconds, the way this
stuff coming in from the source
would start piling up
and your buffers would overflow
and it wouldn't work.
The signals u sub k are
complex numbers.
Or real 2-tuples.
So we can, when we're trying
to decide what signal set
we're using, we can just draw
our signals on a plane.
The signal set is a
constellation, then, of m
complex numbers or
real 2-tuples.
So the problem of choosing the
signal set is, how do you
choose m points on
a complex plane.
What problem is that
similar to?
It's similar to the quantization
problem where we
were trying to choose m
representation points.
And it's very close
to that problem.
It's a very similar problems.
Has a few small differences,
but not many.
But, before getting into that,
we want to talk about a
standard QAM signal set.
In a minute I'll explain
why people do that.
And, as you might imagine, a
standard QAM is just a square
array of points.
It's the simplest thing to do,
and sometimes the simplest
thing is the best.
So it's determined by some
distance, d, that you want to
have between neighboring
points.
And given that distance,
d, you just create a
square array here.
The square array means
that m has to have an
integer square root.
This is drawn for m equals 16.
If you look at this, you see
that the real part of this
it's the standard PAM set.
The imaginary part is a standard
PAM set, which says
you can deal with the real part
and the imaginary part
separately.
You take half the bits coming
in and you choose your real
part signal.
Take the other half of
the bits coming in.
You form your imaginary
part signal, and
bingo, you're all done.
The energy per 2D signal, we
can find the energy for 2D
signal by looking
at it this way.
It's two PAM systems running
in parallel to each other.
For the PAM system, the energy
in one of these dimensions is
then d squared times the square
root of n squared,
minus 1 divided by 12.
But now we want to look at the
energy which we have in both
the real part and the
imaginary part.
So we need this extra factor.
Well, we need to add together
two of these things.
So we wind up with d squared
times m minus 1 divided by 6.
Big deal.
Choosing a good signal set is
similar to choosing a 2D set
of representation points
in quantization.
If you like to optimize things,
you see this problem
and you say, gee, at least
there's something I can put my
teeth into here.
What's the best way to
choose a signal set?
And we found that for
quantization that wasn't a
terribly nice problem, although
at least we had
things like algorithms to try
to choose reasonable sets.
And we then looked at entropy
quantization and things like
this, and it was a certain
amount of fun.
Here, this problem
it's just ugly.
There's no other way
to express it.
I had to be convinced of this.
I once spent an inordinate
amount of time trying to find
the best signal set with eight
points in it, in two
dimensions.
How do you put eight single
points in two dimensions in
such a way that every point is
distance at least d from every
other point, and you
minimize the energy
of the set of points?
The answer is just
absolutely ugly.
It has no symmetry.
Nothing nice about it.
You do the same thing for
16 points, and it's
just an ugly problem.
You do the same thing for
any number of points.
Except for four points.
For four points, it's easy.
For four points, you use
standard QAM and it's the best
thing to do.
And that problem is easy.
But you know, that's
not much fun.
Because you say, bleugh.
So, partly for that
reason, people use
standard signal sets.
Partly because you don't seem
to be able to gain much by
doing anything else.
So that's about all we can say
about standard -- oh, with
eight signals, you can't use
a standard signal set.
That was one reason we had
to worry about it.
Back a long time ago, we were
trying to design a 7200 bit
per second modem.
Back in the days when people
did 2400 bits per second.
And we managed to do 4800
bits per second by
using QAM, big deal.
And then we said, well, we can
pile in an extra bit by using
three bits per two dimensions
instead of two bits.
And spent this enormous amount
of time trying to find a
sensible signal set.
I don't even want to tell you
what it was, because it wasn't
interesting at all.
So, enough for signal sets.
The next thing is, how do
you turn the signals
into complex waveforms?
Namely, how do you go from the
signals in two dimensions,
complex signals into a baseband
waveform u of t?
Well, fortunately, Nyquist's
theory is exactly the same
here as it was when we were
dealing with PAM.
Everything we said before
works here.
The only difference is that you
don't have to choose the
pulse p of t to be real.
But if you look back at what we
did, we didn't assume that
p of t was real before,
anyway.
We just said, you might as well
choose it to be real.
But you don't have to choose
it to be real.
Bandedge symmetry requires
that g of t be real.
Anybody know why that is?
When you choose g of t to be
real, the negative frequency
part is the complex
conjugate of the
positive frequency part.
Which is why, when we took
this out-of-band stuff at
negative frequencies, piled it
into the positive frequencies,
we got the same thing as if we
simply rotate it around on the
positive frequency.
So that bandedge symmetry
condition really requires that
g of t be real.
The orthogonality of t a t
minus k t, this set of
waveforms, requires
g of t to be real.
Neither of these things require
p of t to be real.
You can choose p of t to have
any old phase characteristic
you want to, but if we're
choosing p of t -- if we're
choosing p hat of f magnitude
to be the square root of a
Nyquist waveform, then you can
choose this phase to be
anything you want to make it.
But you're just restricted in,
aside from the phase, you're
somewhat restricted in
what p of t can be.
OK.
So we're going to make the
nominal passband, Nyquist
band, with 1 over t.
Before we made the passband --
before we made the baseband
bandwidth 1 over 2t.
When we go up the passband we
double the bandwidth so the
Nyquist bandwidth
is now 1 over t.
The passband bandwidth
is 1 over t.
That's the only thing
that's changed.
Usually people design these
filters, which they design at
baseband, to go 5-10% over
the Nyquist band.
In other words, these filters
are very, very sharp, usually.
I mean, once you design
a filter, it
doesn't cost anything.
You put it on a chip and
that's the end of it.
And the cost of it is zero.
So it's just the cost to design
it, so you might as
well make it small.
So finally, we want
to go to base,
from baseband to passband.
We talked about this
a little bit.
In terms of these frequencies,
the baseband frequency b sub
u, we want to assume
that that's less
than the carrier frequency.
This is this condition that we
needed to make sure that the
positive frequency part
-- ah, here it is.
That's the condition that
makes sure that this is
separated from that, and doesn't
cause intersymbol
interference between the two.
So, everything we do, we'll
make this assumption.
I mean, a part of this is, if
you're going to modulate with
such a small carrier frequency,
you might as well
not do it at all.
You might as well just
generate the
waveform you want directly.
Because you don't gain that much
by doing it at baseband.
Because you don't really have
a baseband in that case.
So, u of t times e to the 2 pi
i f c t is strictly in the
positive frequency band, then.
And these two bands
don't overlap.
As I said before, we're
going to view this as
two different steps.
The first step is, I'm going
to take this complex
waveform, u of t.
Multiply it by a complex
sinusoid, which shifts me up
in frequency.
Just going to call that
u passband of t.
This is this passband signal
that I want to think about.
The thing that's up in
positive frequencies.
I'm going to ignore the thing
at negative frequencies.
And then I'm going to form the
actual waveform x sub t, as
this plus its conjugate.
If you think a little bit now,
you can see that since these
two bands are separated, if you
think in terms of complex
waveforms, how do you retrieve
this band up here by a
waveform which has
both bands in it?
Well, you filter out what's at
negative frequencies, OK?
So we want to design a filter
which filters out the negative
frequencies and x of t, and
only leaves the positive
frequencies.
In other words, you want a
filter whose frequency
response is just 1 for all
positive frequencies, 0 for
all negative frequencies.
And that filter is called
a Hilbert filter.
Have any of you ever heard of
a Hilbert filter before?
I don't know of anybody
that's ever built one.
And we'll see why they don't
built them in a while.
But it's a nice idea.
I mean, if you try to build
one you'll find that it's
harder to build --
you'll find that you have to
implement four real filters in
order to implement
this filter.
So we'll find out that's
not the thing to do.
But it's nice conceptually
because it lets us study
things like energy, power,
and linearity, and
all of these things.
So the transmitter then becomes
this thing you start
out with a complex waveform
of baseband.
You shift it up in frequency.
This gives you this
high frequency
waveform, u sub p of t.
You then take 2 times the
real part of that to
find the real waveform.
We won't worry about
how to implement
this, you just do it.
This passband waveform, you
then pass it through this
Hilbert filter, which just
chops off the negative
frequency part of it.
Gives you a complex
waveform again.
You multiply by e to the minus 2
pi i f c t, which takes this
positive frequency waveform,
shifts it
back down to baseband.
So this is a nice convenient way
of thinking about, how do
you go from baseband up to
passband and passband down to
baseband again.
Now.
If you want to view these
vectors here as vectors, want
to view u of t as a vector in
L2, there's an important thing
here going on.
We'll have to talk about it
a good deal later on.
This is a complex waveform.
You want to deal with it as
a vector in complex L2.
In complex L2, when we're
dealing with vectors, we have
scalars, which are
complex numbers.
When we start dealing with real
parts of these things, we
want to view the real parts as
being elements of real L2.
Where the scalars are
real numbers.
And what this says is that real
L2 is not a subspace of
complex L2.
It's not a subspace because
the scalars are different.
This might sound like
mathematical nitpicking.
But, put it in the back
of your mind.
Because at some point
it's going to come
up and clobber you.
And at that point, you will
want to think that in fact
real L2 is not a subspace
of complex L2.
When we start thinking about
orthonormal expansions for u
of t and orthonormal expansions
for x of t, in fact
you have to be quite
careful about this.
Because you take an orthonormal
expansion here,
translate it up into
frequency.
And you wind up with a bunch
of complex waveforms.
And they aren't real
waveforms.
And funny things start
happening.
So we'll deal with all
of that later.
This is just to warn you
that we have to be
careful about that.
This is not the way people
implement these things.
Because these Hilbert filters
are in fact for real filters.
So the implementation
is what you've seen.
I mean, the implementation
is old.
And it's the way you want
to build these things.
You start out with two real
baseband waveforms.
One which we call the
real part of u of t.
One which we call the imaginary
part of u of t.
In this single diagram, one
of them is the stuff
that goes this way.
And the other one is the stuff
And if, in fact, you're using a
standard QAM signal set, the
two are completely independent
of each other.
So the real part of u of t is
just the sum of these shifted
pulses times the real parts.
This is the sum of the
shifted pulses
times the complex parts.
The defined u sub k prime is a
real part, and u sub k double
prime is the imaginary part.
In the notes, this and this are
called a sub k and a sub k
double prime.
Which doesn't correspond
to anything else.
So, this is the correct
way of doing it.
But, anyway, when you get all
done, x sub t is 2 times the
cosine of this low pass
modulated PAM waveform.
Minus 2 times the sine
of this low pass
PAM modulated waveform.
So, QAM, when you look at it
this way, is simply two
different PAM systems.
One of them modulated on a
cosine carrier, one of them
modulated on a sine carrier.
And the picture of
that is this.
Aargh.
Can't keep my notation
straight.
I'm sure it doesn't bother most
of you that much, but it
bothers me.
All of those a's
should be u's.
They were a's last year,
but they don't make
any sense as a's.
So the thing we're going to do
now is we start out with the
sequence of signals.
The real part of the
signals and the
imaginary part of the signals.
This is why it's called double
side band quadrature carrier,
because in fact we're doing two
different things in parallel.
We generate this as
a pulse waveform.
We filter it by p of t.
We're thinking of p of t
as a real waveform now.
If you want p of t to be complex
you have to modify
this all a little bit.
But there's no real reason to
make p of t complex anyway.
So when you get out of here,
what you have is just this low
pass real waveform,
real PAM waveform.
Here's another low pass
You module this up by
multiplying by cosine of 2 pi
f c t, in fact, by 2 cosine
of 2 pi f ct .
You modulate this up by
multiplying by minus sine.
And you get the actual
waveform that
you're going to transmit.
How do you demodulate this?
Well, again, I'm sure you've
seen it in one of the
undergraduate courses
you've taken.
Because if you take this
waveform, which is the sum of
this and this, and you multiply
this by cosine of 2
pi f c t, what's going
to happen?
Taking this waveform and
multiplying it by cosine is
going to take this
cosine waveform.
Half of it goes up in frequency
by f sub c.
The other half goes down in
frequency by f sub c of t.
When you multiply by sine,
the same thing happens.
And all of the stuff at this
double frequency term all gets
filtered out.
I mean, you have enough
filtering to
just wash that away.
And you wind up, just with this
one waveform which is the
result of this.
Another waveform which is
the result of this.
You can show that the two don't
interfere at all, and
you just have to do
the multiplication
to find this out.
It looks a little bit like black
magic when you look at
it like this.
Because when you're multiplying
by a cosine wave,
I mean it's easy to see what
cosine squared does here.
But it's a little harder
to see what
happens to all of this.
And when we look at it the
other way, which was this
Hilbert filter kind of thing,
when you look at in terms of
the Hilbert filter it's quite
clear that you can filter out
the lower sideband and then you
can just go back down to
baseband again.
So it's very clear that
the whole thing works.
Except you wouldn't implement
it this way.
Here you have to be more careful
to see that works.
But in fact you would.
Well, after you get all done,
then you get these baseband
PAM waveforms back again.
You sample them after
filtering.
And you're all done.
With that, we are almost done
with what we want to do with
modulating up to passband
and down to baseband.
We'll spend a little bit of
time reviewing a couple of
minor points on this
next time.
Like, I guess, the main thing
we have to talk about is how
do you do frequency recovery,
which is kind of a neat thing.
And then we'll go on to talking
about random processes
and how you deal with noise.
So.
If you want to read ahead, we
will probably have the notes
on random processes on the
web sometime tomorrow
afternoon or Sunday.
Thanks.